is the new leader of the Sinquefield
cava Fabiano Guerra Juana
well he's been languishing for a little
while then he won a game and tied for
first but now he's won yet another and
burst the head of the rest of the pack
Fabiano Caruana
in first place probably tell us about
this opening you played very quickly in
the very beginning and then he played a
move that had you stopping to think for
a little bit but then the game
proceeding you took control yeah I just
noticed that Wesley played this line
against machine blitz yeah we looked and
we looked at the research we thought you
were following this line yeah it's it's
an interesting line I I think also I
think I think also ownership has played
a number of games in this line with
Queen I for I think he played against
narrative skiing
he was Championships we didn't find any
games in the exact us not would be sure
he told over 95 yes which is the main
the which is most commonly played I'm
Bishop d7 look at Queen c2 was what
Wesley played but I think that fish was
probably just much more challenging I
mean it was briefly checked today okay a
five is probably not a good move any
black has some options after Bishop c5
but he is under a lot of positional
pressure and especially if you don't
know the positions it's actually very
unpleasant I thought that I just got a
very nice position
I thought maybe Bishop c3 is not
necessary you can play Bishop d6 Queen C
for a4 it's still rather unpleasant but
I mean at least he avoids exact torture
in the game where I had the open B file
and he can't ever really improve his
position but what he did is it can't be
so bad I mean he's not more than
slightly Wurster so take us the next few
moves you know do you think where do you
think that it became much worse I think
that he played quite well for the next
few moves yeah I wasn't sure I played
the best but anyway I think I played
normal moves yeah
Bishop c6
Queen B 5 I don't know if Queen eight is
necessary I had the Queen when the Queen
goes say the work on a7 almost always a
game shutout like and and it really a
lot of lines black experiences tactical
problems because the work on it said and
it can only go to a5 but see you end up
with a weak back rank surprisingly but I
don't know if if it's a bad move I just
I just thought that he should kind of
keep more of a central prep central
presence but anyway I mean you can't it
can't be that bad
I think we played logical moves I think
if I was a good little bit after g5 i I
thought that might I find is a correct
choice because Queen a for and I'd be
southern I I think he should be happy to
get rid of this pawn even if he doesn't
take away three she should be right
happy to get rid of this just to get
some sort of blockade with ninety five
and if I have a lot of options without
taking but nothing very clear-cut
because if I move my knight now then
might be three comes c5 is no longer
very good because it work takes t5 and
kind of importantly there's no Queen e8
major with an idol b8 there is so so see
if I was not working out anymore and I
was thinking like maybe work do you want
or something as possible just keeping
the option of 94 after 97 and some
positional pressure but nothing which
shouldn't be manageable but of course
black will have to suffer for a long
time with no clear upside but then the
gaming I did I this just allows me I
think a very strong moves c5 which kind
of immediately caught my eye because
it's I mean I don't want Tim to get 97
I'd rather open the position while all
his pieces are misplaced
so first error was 98 he's gonna make a
bigger error soon yeah I thought there
was some nice lines like if Queen d5
instead of rope a5 here I play C b6
Queen B 5 is forced and he takes a 7
I even thought like Queenie one might be
one is the most accurate and just take
off C 7
yeah this is this is horrible
so you so after C found I thought maybe
[Music]
this is losing so I thought maybe C 5 bc
5 which is ugly but I don't know if luck
should already be in it in a state of
desperation because the point is Queen
c5 Knight a6 and then next one feels I
wrote d5 and although it looks awkward
and might not even be good it still I
have to prove that I'm going to have an
a strong leadership for the pawn so I
was playing instead rook c5 and then 97
Brooks e6 something like this well that
I still thought it's there's still
plenty to calculate but if I do
consolidate Woody for he'll be busted I
mean just everything week look in the
game it looked even worse I mean okay
fine
yeah maybe - this is all forced I'd c4
c5 I think Queenie six is a very strong
move because Knight b6 is the most
natural move rook C one roof so you want
Queen b3 and it's so and creamy threes
probably only moved to keep his bones
it's still a fight I thought we threw p1
is very strong but anyway and I here
would be one word e3 and this this is
probably going to be a trough but like
rook e1 immediately instead of Queen b3
but it's hard to note this is it's very
close to be nothing like rook do you
wanna take Queen takes King G - it's
probably still bad for black but you
know it it's basically a matter of one
tempo
yeah kingi 296 and like Queen I just be
five but anyway I once I saw Queen b6 I
didn't spend any more time on this I
just thought I just started calculating
it and at first it it seemed like the
tactics won't work in my favor but every
time with the each line I calculated the
tactics started working more and more in
my favor like 96 at first it looks like
a very consolidated but then 92 comes
Brooksie one would see one and rook d1
is a threat Knight is hanging a force
hanging so I think he's he's busted here
just too many threats and then I thought
the main move was rook ain't worked five
to c8 which almost looks like it just
equalize himself at first then I noticed
96 works yeah ninety-seven might see it
kind of or work see it and I see it
picks up the queen with the 97 and I
show that all right I see a 97
bringing the exchange
at least well I wouldn't back the
exchange and I just clean up and he so
he now gets to take take and play rook a
fade I guess he had to go for this which
has a tactical justification that might
see it he has Queen d2 and and he
doesn't lose on the squad but but I
think I have just so many good moves
here I thought even like just rooks e7
dominating everything and my king he has
no perpetual x' no options a
professional just slowly should be
killing or maybe I could just trade
Queens and win win a pawn and win this
ending I mean but still I would have to
work hard for the win well in the game
he just bumped it up six yeah if six was
the jar eyes just light up when I'm six
workers I I mean this move just looked
wrong on on many levels I assume there's
more than one refutation here but I
didn't bother calculating more than
whoopty one because the move kind of
immediately jumped out are you surprised
by how poorly he's performing at this
tournament cuz he's he's not really
playing very well either
he's just he just looks like not Sergei
yeah he's having a bad tournament I mean
he was also suffering in the in the
Blitz he didn't play at his normal level
which which is kind of I mean it
happened watching some bad formula Apes
I mean every player can empathize with
the player who for whom nothing is going
right in the tournament you know I'm so
happy that I managed to take it right
that's your problem obviously well were
you paying attention to the game Rick
Carlson because we all just thought
death is gonna come to Carlson how many
ways can he die and then all of a sudden
the game turns around there's a few
moves and it's a draw yeah I assumed
there was winning but it always did look
kind of messy I didn't spend too much
time calculating lines but I assume that
what should be objectively winning at
some point and then I looked back to the
board a few minutes later and I saw this
position after working for and then no
longer looked like anything you have
been two points away from Magnus on the
number one for the number one spot in
the world which has not changed in eight
years
but you do get a shot of him tomorrow
what should we expect from tomorrow's
battle everybody's been waiting for the
Super Saturday matchup between the two
of you as you guys will be playing a
match for the world championship title
you're now in first place as well so
that does factor into it a little bit
yeah I assume he'll be trying very hard
to to get into elite I mean it's an
important game in general but also very
important in terms of the tournament
standings so and so I assume he'll try
to like heart in this game and you I
mean also try going for the win or just
play I mean that's it's not I like
playing I just playing normally if
chances arise then I'll try to take that
invoked I'm also playing black so it's
not like it's not like you get better
positions automatically with like you
know it if chances are come then I'll
try to take them but otherwise you know
what role would also be quite a good
result we look forward to that matchup
tomorrow congratulations on taking the
lead and your win and get your rest and
your preparation thank you